it's been some time since he-man ruled
the world but the once mighty tv and toy
phenomenon is finally ready for a reboot
whether you're a longtime fan or a
newcomer here are all the reasons why
netflix's masters of the universe will
blow your mind from here to eternium
it took what felt like forever but we
now have a definitive answer
masters of the universe revelation will
debut on netflix on friday july 23
2021. when filmmaker kevin smith the
geek icon producer of the revelation
miniseries first announced the show at
anaheim's powercon 2019 it was difficult
to tell just how far along the series
was in the production pipeline but the
team behind the show obviously went
right to work if they managed to wrap up
production in the year and a half since
then while in the midst of a global
pandemic
we should note that july 23rd is only
the first part of the season with five
episodes going up for streaming on that
date
hopefully we'll get some indication
about the second batch of revelation
episodes soon after the initial premiere
smith took to twitter in november 2019
to share that the voice cast was about
to begin recording their parts though
that means the second half shouldn't be
too far away
if this is the case netflix will need to
figure out where it can fit the second
half of revelation into its release
schedule
of course we'll be keeping an eye out
for an official announcement which we
expect to arrive sooner rather than
later
netflix doesn't shy away from positive
pr when they know viewers are flocking
to a new show
as shown when bridgerton obliterated all
previous records for viewership on the
streaming service
if masters of the universe revelation
turns out to be the hit that netflix
hopes it will be they won't waste any
time moving up the release of the
remaining episodes for the series
masters of the universe revelation is
already proving to be far glitzier than
the 80s series we all know and love with
its illustrious cast of
aaa talent he-man will have his shouts
and war cries powered by chris wood of
supergirl and the vampire diaries fame
the biggest scat of the series however
is without a doubt mark hamill
in a truly inspired casting choice he
will be lending his incredible voice
talents to iconic villain skeletor
hamill may still be most well known for
playing luke skywalker in the star wars
franchise but he's almost as famous for
his stellar body of voice acting work
he has consistently performed an
animated version of the joker since the
90s
more recently he has been putting his
evil shriek to work as skektec the
scientist in the other big 80s nostalgia
revival series on netflix the dark
crystal age of resistance
so becoming skeletor is a perfect fit
for his style what can we say he's very
good at those unhinged evil cackles
the celebrity train doesn't stop there
as we continue down the long list of
eternia's friends and enemies
the cast includes sarah michelle gellar
as tila liam cunningham as man in arms
lena heady is evil lin diedrick bader is
king randor and trap jaw
alicia silverstone as queen marlena and
many more there's even a role for kevin
conroy the batman to hamilt's joker and
batman the animated series as merman
hello hello operator i believe my
party's been
disconnected
netflix's sparse webpage for the
upcoming masters of the universe
revelation series has a brief
one-sentence blurb as a summary of the
show
that reads after a calamitous battle
fractures eternia tila and an unlikely
alliance must prevent the end of the
universe and the sequel to the 80s
classic
exciting eh netflix's teaser doesn't
provide much more context than that but
by the power of greyskull it does feel
like a direct continuation of the 80
series complete with 95 seconds of
action set to bonnie tyler's holding out
for a hero
like so at the beginning of our first
episode it plays for the first 10
minutes
like you know a slightly or way better
animated version
of the old show there is an interesting
nugget buried in the producing credits
the vp of mattel tv rob david at first
blush that's no big deal because it's
very common for executives of
intellectual properties to receive
executive producing credit
the twist here is that rob david also
came up with the story for the 15 issue
he-man comic series titled the eternity
war
that was published by dc from 2014 to
2016.
the comic story isn't centered only on
skeletor and he-man
instead it's about a no-holds-barred war
for the soul of eternium
with big battles noble sacrifices and
bloody carnage
while this new netflix mini-series is
likely not a direct adaptation
elements from the comics could be
incorporated what the plot of revelation
will probably not include considering
their absence from the cast list is
he-man's sister shira and her many
ancillary characters
netflix's shira and the princesses of
power animated series has no announced
connection to revelation
and the two shows likely won't connect
at all because shira has been running
just fine on its own steam for four
seasons
it appears that we'll just have to wait
to see exactly what kind of story smith
and company are cooking up for us
fortunately the wait is nearly over and
with all the love that smith david and
the rest of the crew are pouring into
this adaptation we're not worried in the
least
if you had any worries about the
professional credentials of the crew
behind the scenes the composer for
masters of the universe revelation
should ease your fears
the animated netflix show's composer is
none other than the award-winning bear
mccreary
long time fans of the walking dead were
introduced to his music from the first
moment to the opening credits
and he remains one of the longest
tenured people attached to the amc show
his career has spanned multiple genres
and mediums mccreary got his start in
television on the 2004 version of
battlestar galactica where he scored
almost all of the 76 episodes of the
sci-fi hit that spawned a new generation
of fans
from there he continued his work on
television by composing music for
several seasons of eureka and terminator
the sarah connor chronicles
mccreary's work is rooted in horror
where he created the music for films
like rest stop and wrong turn 2 dead end
as the star rose he scored bigger and
more widely known movies including 10
cloverfield lane godzilla king of the
monsters and the 2019 reboot of child's
play
one of his biggest professional
accomplishments in recent years however
has come in the form of video games
specifically 2018's god of war the
playstation 4 exclusive was a mega hit
for sony selling more than 10 million
copies in a little over a year after its
release
for his work on the norse mythology
inspired action epic mccreary won a
bafta and four game audio network guild
awards
kevin smith revealed mccreery as a
composer in february 2021
and the netflix geek twitter account
posted a video of smith's reaction to
hearing the metal maestros work for the
first time
smith is left visibly teary-eyed by the
end of the clip which should tell fans
of revelation that the music is in the
most capable of hands
for those of you who just can't wait
until july 23rd dark horse comics is
getting a top tier team of writers and
artists to hold you over before masters
of the universe
revelation premieres four issues of a
prequel comic also titled masters of the
universe revelation are scheduled for
release
with number one now available for
pre-order everywhere comics are sold
kevin smith and rob david two of the
names behind the netflix show are also
in charge of writing the comic series
along with tim sheridan known for his
work on the superman man of tomorrow and
reign of the superman animated movies
the comic has some heavyweights in the
visual department as well with drawings
by mindy lee known for the comics bounty
and crimson lotus
color from rika renzi who you may know
from the comics spider-gwen and
sundowners and letters by darren bennett
known for his work on background
steve sayek a veteran of he-man the
eternity war drew the cover of the first
issue
and dave wilkins will provide covers for
the remaining three issues
each issue will have at least one
variant cover drawn by many other
talented artists
the release of a comic book for masters
of the universe revelation is a nice
callback to the original 80s cartoon
which also contained comic books that
were included with the release of each
new action figure
this prequel is set to explore the
aftermath of an attack on king randor
he-man's father
the creature sent in the attack is
somehow linked to he-man's sword and he
sets off after skeletor and evil lin
masters of the universe revelation
number one will hit comic shelves and
digital storefronts on july 7th
2021. the other three issues were
released on august 11th september 8th on
october 13th
which should help hold us over until the
second half of the revelation series
premieres on netflix
as we mentioned earlier masters of the
universe revelation isn't the only
revival of this series in the works for
netflix
mattel and netflix are also
collaborating on a totally separate
production
simply titled he-man and the masters of
the universe unlike the anime-inspired
revelation this show will reportedly be
a more traditional take on the masters
of the universe mythos with the target
audience reportedly skewing much younger
at the moment details of this new he-man
show are very scarce
we know that the storylines will be new
and that skeletor is the center of the
conflict
the onslaught of he-man lore hasn't
stopped there an additional he-man in
the masters of the universe animated
film is also in the works as well as a
live-action movie
no matter what it'll probably be better
than the last time they tried that
i check out one of our newest videos
right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you